Well, church, it's always a great day to get to see this,
uh, act of obedience, this illustration of salvation.
And so we get to celebrate with the Greenlaw family today.
This is Elliot just had a birthday Thursday,
but we get to celebrate a spiritual marker in his life
as he came to faith and just continued to follow.
Jesus wanted to express that publicly
through this act of baptism.
So we're here today to celebrate with him to do that.
Uh, it's a symbol again of what God has done in his heart,
that spiritually dead, now alive, kind of buried
with Christ, raised in him to follow him the rest
of his life so we can celebrate that today
and to honor Christ in what he's done.
And so, Elliot, based on your profession of faith, I get
to baptize you in the name of the Father, the Son,
and the Holy Spirit.
Amen. Amen.
God, thank you for this, this celebration.
It's not the act of salvation.
It is what you've already done in his heart
and life forever choosing and drawing, and now redeeming
and assuring guaranteeing his salvation forever and ever
because of what Christ has done for him
and his life, death and resurrection.
But Lord, this is an act of obedience.
It's an act of illustration. It's a declaration.
So this is one step of that for the rest of Elliot's life.
God, I pray that his family has done such a good job
pointing him to you.
I pray as a church we would do the same, to continue
to point him in the direction of the path
of righteousness found in you alone, Christ.
Fill him with your spirit. Help him
to look to you in all things.
In Jesus' name, amen.
Amen. Amen. If you would stand with.